that's the most Indian question are you
Indian I knew it it's dark I can't see
but I knew I could tell she hated her
job by the way she asked what do you do
for a living
oh you know I'm so good at judgment hey
let me tell you something if you want to
do this you better make a lot of money
because that's the only thing that'll
shut him up I swear to God my dad said
to me I've been doing this for like 14
years now I'm 37 and my dad said to me
probably six months ago he goes I just
got over you not being a doctor but I
still hold out hope that's what he said
I told my dad and he died three months
later
with a live father probably not for long
when he died he was like like BRB